une semaine pour convaincre un une
semaine pour obtenir une majorité forte
et claire
seule cette majorité forte et claire
nous permettra de répondre aux urgences
qui pèsent sur le quotidien des français
et de relever les défis d'avenir
face à la situation du monde et à la
guerre aux portes de l'europe nous ne
pouvons pas prendre le risque de
l'instabilité et des approximations
face aux extrêmes nous seuls portant un
projet de cohérence de clarté et de
responsabilité j'appelle donc toutes les
forces républicaine à se rassembler
autour de ce projet et de nos candidats
mesdames et messieurs dans une semaine
au delà des étiquettes ce sont nos
valeurs qui sont en jeu
la liberté l'égalité la fraternité et la
laïcité
ce premier tour nous montre que ce
combat est toujours d'actualité et que
nous ne devons jamais cesser de défendre
ses valeurs
car oui comme cela ne s'était jamais
produit dans l'histoire politique de
notre pays nous avons face à nous une
confusion inédite aux extrêmes face aux
extrêmes ne céderons rien ni d'un côté
ni de l'autre
ne céderons rien pour défendre le
progrès social la souveraineté de notre
pays et la république
car rappelons le le progrès social ça
n'est pas la décroissance économique
mais la liberté d'entreprendre et
d'innover pour créer plus d'emplois et
financer notre modèle social
le progrès social ça n'est pas une
écologie d'interdits et de taxes mais
une transition écologique ambitieuse qui
ne laisse personne au bord de la route
la souveraineté nationale ça n'est pas
la rupture avec l'europe la fascination
pour les régimes autoritaires et
l'alignement sur la russie mais bien une
nation forte au sein d'une europe plus
indépendante
la république ça n'est pas la remise en
cause de nos institutions et l'insultent
entre nous forces de l'ordre la
république ça n'est pas monté des
français les contre les autres en les
opposant selon leur religion leur
origine ou leur situation sociale mais
bien la laïcité et l'égalité entre tous
les citoyens
mes chers compatriotes
pour agir pour mettre en oeuvre les
engagements portés par le président de
la république nous avons besoin d'une
majorité forte et engagée
alors durant les jours qui viennent
comme moi toutes les candidates et tous
les candidats de la majorité
présidentielle
continuerons ensemble apporter avec
détermination notre projet celui du
pouvoir d'achat celui d'une grande
nation écologique celui du plein emploi
et du refus des inégalités de destin
dimanche prochain face aux extrêmes en
votant pour les candidats de la majorité
présidentielle vous permettrait à la
france d'être au rendez vous de son
avenir et de ses valeurs vive la
république et vive la france
[Musique]